is there a way to get aging parents to
understand the real value of possessions
that they believe have worth but are
likely worthless so they stop trying to
give away things that someone else will
simply need to throw out so yeah I have
seen plenty of examples of this where
you've got like a maybe it's not like
the the the worst side of the spectrum
hoarding mm-hmm
but you've got people who went on to a
lot of stuff a lot of antiques a lot of
trinkets a lot of things trinkets is a
good word for them and I've been to
these you know I've been to homes like
this and they're like oh you need a
blender literally like I've been this
you need a blender
here's a blender and like the blender
that I get I'm like oh thank you but
it's like it's not you know it's got
weird stains on it and it's just not a
blender that I would ever spend any
money on or like just maybe does have
the feature that didn't have the feature
I need it but I remember taking that
blender was actually a food processor
taking that food processor and then
giving it away in donating it or worse
it could be broken like hey I've got but
you actually it was partially broken but
you can get it fixed right and so
they're essentially I mean they're not
essentially they are quite literally
handing you trash
yeah and it's it it doesn't it seems
different but it's not appreciably
different from if I were to go into my
trashcan pull out the trash bag and say
hey Ryan you need this you know what I
do as a minimalist when I meet these
people Josh you scorn them and you go
like this with your fingers out out to
our YouTube viewers I take the item when
I say thank you yeah and that's it ma'am
yeah because it you know at that point
like I'm not going to I'm not gonna help
them by scoring them yeah I'm not
helping them by projecting my own
insecurities at them
I am yeah I'm not gonna change them by
there's no magic sentence I could say
that's gonna make them stop hoarding
well I wrote something down here this
isn't my short answer but it echoes with
exactly what you said you don't have to
be mean to be honest and we can provide
feedback without questioning someone's
intentions
and so a few short answers here patience
is paramount
sometimes we have no patience people
because hey you know what it took me
personally 29 years to get to minimalism
right right now all of a sudden I'm
going to expect you to change over the
long holiday weekend or something it
doesn't work that way and so it's about
having patience feel to people so what
you're displaying there when you take
that thing is you're having patience now
you can still show them through your
actions not through well you know what
this is a piece of junk that's that's
that helpful so it's about being helpful
still it's still being kind yeah
although here's what I'll say and here's
my pity answers most gift horses have
tooth decay they say don't look a gift
horse in the mouth
but I think that's nonsense I've never
understood that saying what ok the
saying is don't like so back in there
you got a gift horse wait [ __ ] is a gift
tours a gift horse like a horse that's
been gifted to me yeah yes ok there
would be a gift like a nice gift
ok I'm giving you thanks for a horse so
don't look it in the mouth because
because sometimes people just give you a
horse that's dying and you could tell
because they had rotting teeth if they
had bad teeth okay and so someone gave
you a gift horse first thing people do
look at the TV goes like I don't want to
care for this rotting horse if you give
me a dying horse I don't have to deal
with it so realize that if you're
getting a gift maybe it's it's not an
actual gift now that I understand what
this idiom means I don't agree with it
here's a gift here's a rotting gift
uh-huh so the term don't look a gift
horse in the mouth means just take the
shut up and take the gift that's that's
why I say I don't agree with it I say
most gift horses have to get some so
look out for that and realize that the
more I guess I'm really saying is most
gifts aren't necessarily gifts but also
junk is in the eye of the beholder so
maybe they really thought they were
giving you something really nice and and
they thought they were being caring and
and that's why you the way you approach
is okay thank you very much have a nice
day
and then you once it's your thing you
get to determine what you do with your
thing you know it's kind of if you think
about it like people who let's go with
the horse or the blender for that
I have a really I have a horse with
tooth decay maybe it's got three three
good years left right I give it to you
here here's here's a gift horse it's
kind of it's kind of selfish for me to
be like yeah I don't want to I don't
want to take the last three years out of
this horse you know it's it's it's it's
already dying but here Josh he can take
the last three days oh I don't want this
blender because yes I have a better
blender I have a better food processor
here's one that's slightly broken
slightly damaged so I'm gonna pawn that
off on someone else
yeah so they can get the maximum life
out of it yeah that just that seems
that's a horrible saying horrible say my
short answer is this it's difficult oh
wait no my short answer is this you
can't fix a problem until you see the
problem so how do you get a hoarder or
someone older or you know person in your
life who really value sentimental items
how to view them differently you really
there's nothing you can do to change
their perspective there's nothing you
can say to them what you can do is you
can live a meaningful life you can show
them by example what what it means to
live a simplified life yeah and if they
look at you and think oh wow that person
looks really happy I'm gonna start
applying some of their principles in my
life because they seem like they're
living a really happy life if that
person is looking at you and saying oh
my god how can they how can they live
without a garage full of boxes filled
with trinkets and junk I don't know how
they live their life that way that's
crazy I love my junk that's that and
that's their preference right and well
it goes back to what Riley was saying if
you shine a bright enough light you will
illuminate the flaws but in this case
you're shining the light on a more
meaningful life a less cluttered life a
calmer stiller life maybe that's gonna
look appealing to them instead of me
saying you need to get rid of your stuff
say wow look how calm this is
you